Einstein did a lot of great things for
science but working in the patent office
at least from the perspective of
modern-day physicist was a real
disservice and I mean that in the
following way that you already
understand which is so many people think
you don't need to be within the
community you can be off in left field
just having big thoughts and you'll
change the world on occasion that
happens it certainly happened once but
for most of us we're embedded in a
community and there's an ongoing
conversation sometimes it's a real
conversation times it's reading other
people's papers and so dayto day that's
what we do we are pursuing mathematical
developments and trying to see what
Insight we can extract from them